hello everyone this is samir from
audiosounds review uh today i have an
unusual review for you it's an in-wall
speaker from ravel the speaker company
um the model number is w553l
you can see a picture of it in here but
it may be easier to look at it at the
retailer uh
site
um it's the front of it got a tweeter
it's got a little adjustment i think for
the highs plus or minus one db
the tweeter can be positioned which is
nice and you can see the guts of it in
the back here uh you know nothing fancy
but you know good design uh that's gone
into it it comes with a pretty grill
as these things usually do and let you
hide things although i didn't measure it
with with that
the standard mounting of these rotating
um
screws
you put the speaker in then you screw it
tight in these little tabs um
these little tabs in here
will rotate and and grab the side of the
drywall or whatever
plywood or plaster whatever you have on
this thing
so with that let's get back into the
review um
traditionally this kind of speaker is
very difficult to measure measure um
because obviously it has no back box and
if i just put the speaker on the stand
in here and try to measure it
i get diffraction
artifacts from the edges over here as
the sound wraps around and and
re-re-radiates around these corners and
also the back wave
from these drivers comes forward and
cancels things out so you get a
a measurement that doesn't look anything
like when you install this in a wall and
none of those effects happen because
when it's on the wall there's no sharp
edge here anymore
although not you know maybe there's a
little bit but
nothing like when you stand alone and
the back wave doesn't travel and come
forward um fortunately this uh clippable
near field scanner that i use and you
can barely see the stand that it's on uh
says special module uh very expensive
cost 4 000 euros just for the software
uh about five or six thousand dollars
and what it will do and this is a
microphone by the way and i've put
absorbers around it to stop the
reflections from the uh microphone stand
because this speaker
this when the sound waves get the app
the wavelength gets small enough they
become significant relative to the
dimensions of the
microphone mount that's on a boom here
and they reflect back and then reflect
forward and so forth so you get a little
bit of comb filtering but fortunately
the wavelength is is small so you can
put just one or two inches of uh
padding in there and it'll absorb it and
uh i borrowed uh quilt padding from my
wife and uh made a makeshift one and
it's worked and i haven't messed with it
anyway
the way clippable uh near-field scanner
works in in this mode is that it will
take the speaker and it will make a scan
that circular scan around the speaker's
front so it will scan a
hemisphere
around the speaker centered around the
twitter and then it will make a
secondary one a little bit outside of
that
and using those two hemispheric
scans it's able to detect if sound is
moving out in this direction or is
coming back from the other way based on
his timing so um there there will be
diffraction off of these edges so these
act like little small speakers just like
this would have
and they come back at us but
uh couple mfs
is able to exclude that in software
later on in this computational path
because it knows that notice that the
timing of those is way different than
the timing of forward firing sound
source same with the rear reflections
the rear reflections will have to bounce
off of walls and other things before
they come forward and the timing changes
and is able to detect that and excluded
as well so the bottom line is that
measurements you're about to see reflect
as if this
speaker was mounted in a wall that's
infinitely large that means no effect
from the
back and no effect around edges of this
thing these edges do not exist in the
measurements you're going to see and
that makes a huge difference when you
measure a speaker like this i've done it
without this and it's completely
different and very unreliable
if you build a back box for it just as
well as is broken and
because you get diffraction around the
edges the back box has to be sealed and
it's just it's a mess and i started that
way trying to economize without the
software module and it just doesn't work
so
uh this is the way to do it um
it's uh
the system has got some limitations
maybe at some some point i'll talk about
but in this case it actually is pretty
ideal and worked well with this um it is
a lot of hassle measuring these speakers
because every one of them the sizes are
not standardized so i you know you have
to build this baffle
and mount the speaker in it and then
mount this on on the stand and
uh you know while i'm a woodworker in
wintertime my woodworking job is remote
i don't want to go out there and raid
and try to cut this out this case the
owner was kind enough to go ahead and
build this for me to the spec that i
gave him has to be pretty large to allow
for the dual scan and uh he made the uh
made this and i added the registration
points and then the mounting system that
that i use in here
so bottom line
we're seeing an echoic uh
measurements of the speaker in wild
speaker uh
and which in your real installation in a
wall on a wall it'll be very very close
to this
i must say i was very impressed with the
frequencies actually let me before i get
there let me cover this note i founded a
company called madrid digital about
14 15 years ago after i left microsoft
and madrid digital's business is they do
custom integration for very high-end
customers both on commercial and
residential those mostly residential
and we don't do any retail but we source
a lot of products for many companies and
medrona i mean uh harmon parent company
of revell is one we use uh the
application products and we use their
revel speakers a lot of involved in
ceiling speakers i don't know if we do
this um but uh nothing comes to us from
this kind of review
madrona is an independent company i've
founded that you know run audio science
review they have nothing to do with each
other and me giving a good or bad review
to the speaker doesn't amount to
anything for us because we don't sell
speakers like this one off somebody can
come to us and buy them but uh it's not
a business that we're in we're not a
retail shop we have no showroom um our
typical customer pays us more for uh
security than they will ever do for
audio system
okay
so with that anything subjective you're
welcome to read bias into it but
measurements i can't cook the
measurements i set up this bigger like
any other speaker any other brand and
stuff comes out
so speaking of stuff coming out this is
our traditional spinorama uh or cea2034
measurement uh most important
measurement i look at that at first is
this black line which is the on axis
response and i put a reference line in
red and this is extremely good for any
passive speaker let alone one that's
designed to go involved in wall speakers
as a rule the business is all about just
selling something that has an invisible
grill and and making money for the
company and an installer
you know getting quality to be good is
not remotely important to them most
customers buy these in walls they just
put them as you know sound everywhere
and they don't care about fidelity but
in this case uh harman and revel group
certainly has put in work to make sure
that the tonality of this speaker is
very neutral uh yes there's little ups
and downs in here the clippable nfs has
very high resolution in there
but it's it's extremely clean for you
know speakers you could take the speaker
mounted in a wall and be a high-five
speaker and and or in a box and be a
high-five speaker ready to go uh it has
this gentle slope because it's um it's
not ported even though the whole back is
open in this case remember it pretends
as if the back doesn't exist so you get
this nice uh nice it's a gently you know
rolling down whereas if you had a port
you get more extension but then the drop
is a lot faster
so these tend to be easier to cross to a
subwoofer which is a good thing because
you don't want an involved speaker like
this generating a lot of bass because
you can rattle things off the wall you
can even crack the paint and and it's
not easy to make it you know drywall at
least in the u.s to be very rigid so um
you know it's good that you don't get a
ton of you know sub-bass certainly um
the other thing which is unusual for
ravel speakers the sensitivity in here
is quite high this is around almost 90
db efficient and the reason for that is
that that infinite wall allows
us to get
reinforcement and not have to do what is
called baffle compensation
so we can let the drivers do their best
job they can with by sort of projecting
things forwards like a flashlight uh
concentrating and sound energy coming
forward so um
so very good in here and that means even
if you have modest amplification you get
good dynamics uh top use for these
speakers is is in home theater as a
surrounds or fronts
behind your screen and
there you want dynamics and this thing
will deliver so you can take a standard
avr and drive it and then get very good
sound
early reflections
this is designed for standalone speakers
away from a while it's a little bit
inaccurate but more or less we can go by
it and shows how well behaved the
speaker is we can see that the response
is very close to the uh on axis except
it slopes down as it should and it dips
a little bit in here the dipping is
caused by these two strong reflections
vertically that have much less energy
around here and there are ceiling on the
floor
um i hope if you're building a home
theater that you have a carpet in it
it's a good place to put lots of
absorption in there
and if you have carpet in there this
goes away or mostly attenuates and then
this comes up and notice that his
frequency is about two kilohertz just
like i talked about the padding around
my microphone to absorb two kilohertz
you don't need to have a six inch
absorber just two or three inches uh
will do a lot and even one inch will do
it so make sure you have a thick carpet
in your uh or good thick padding that's
breathable underneath your carpet uh for
your uh home theater if that's where
you're using it but even if you did
nothing it still would be quite good
this is a very very modest dip in here
it's not consequential and you can see
its effect here where again for
standalone speaker we could predict this
response if you put it in a box and put
it in a room we see that has a nice
slope down which is what you want
otherwise it sounds too bright we see
that a little bit of deviation i talked
about in here which you can try to eq
even though it's a directivity error
some research shows that you can boost
this up if you wanted to two or three db
in here
i wouldn't mess with it unless you you
know you really had time to experiment
but it shows you how nice this is that
it competes with a
standalone speaker in here
and so nothing unusual there
our near field measurements where i
stick the microphone right at the
drivers doesn't show anything uh out of
ordinary and the reason for that is that
we don't have a port so nothing's
interfering and
luckily nothing's rattling or anything
and the response is pretty good
the crossover maybe could be a little
bit lower order but a higher order but
uh doesn't matter because the overall
response is something well
now we get into very unusual graphs in
here um and they're unusual because if
you haven't looked at any in-wall
speaker measurements which i've done a
few and i'm showing them in that because
you have walls around the uh driver uh
you know basically nothing can go behind
and all of that gets reflected forward
so the speaker has basically plus or
minus uh you know it's fully just a
sound that comes at you and it's only at
the highest frequencies where the
tweeter grabs it then becomes more and
more directional and that twitter takes
over around four or five kilohertz and
becomes directional but when it gets
directional it's still very controlled
it's not doesn't do the classic thing
where it keeps getting worse
and so design has gone into making sure
that that stays controlled and flat and
so what that means is that tonality
won't shift when you're left and right
which in a home theater is important
because you have a bunch of seats in
there and you want to make sure your
tonality doesn't shift so overall it's
very nice you can see the effect in here
as a color coded this is the same as
that one just presented differently
i don't know why clipple shows plus or
minus 180 degrees in this graph this is
we would normally cover all the way
behind the speaker horizontally but
in this case doesn't make sense because
the walls will stop you from going
behind the speaker so it's this chart is
not valid past these points and but if
you look in here you can see this plus
or minus 50 degrees this nice red
channel in here and there's no uh you
know blue and green stuck in the middle
of it that would cause uh holes in the
response of axis response so bottom line
this means is good
vertically whenever you have uh two
drivers there's the same
which in this case is the two woofers
and
if you're at a different distance for to
one versus the other the the other
waveform will get delayed
more than the the other one the primary
one and that delay causes two waveforms
to then cancel uh at different
frequencies and that's the effect you're
getting over here now if you go a few
degrees
nothing happens so you want to stay plus
or minus 20 degrees vertically
so as long as your the timing difference
is slight you know you're okay when you
go very extreme then all of a sudden
things go bad uh on this thing so
um
you want to in general point this uh you
know put it at the ear height if you can
or within
20 degrees
i don't know how you would tilt the
woofers which is the problematic area
here
so but for your fronts for example if
you're using this behind the
acoustically transparent screen i would
put them lower than higher
within 20 degrees of of your ears
wherever you're sitting so don't put
them way up in the center of the screen
shooting sound above your head bring it
down if you have a screen doesn't matter
whether you have wherever you have them
so make sure that shaft of sound is
within that envelope and comes at you
on this thing but it's a classic problem
we have with center speakers that are
rotated then we get this problem
horizontal axis which is really bad in
this case we have it in the vertical
axis
and you know you could eliminate it by
taking out one of the drivers but then
you lose a lot of power handling and
i'll show you in a second how good the
distortion characteristics are well
let's jump into that
and
you know at the 86 db spl this thing is
is not even crossing my 50 db threshold
for distortion is extremely clean even
at 96 db is still you know motoring
along with you know very little
distortion this critical bands where
it's audible over here still very good
base distortion is well below 100
percent whereas a lot of ported designs
the distortion because you know above
100
so very good and you can see it down
here you know look at the distortion
down here it's extremely low well below
half a percent over here and almost
negligible in certain frequencies and at
960p nothing crazy happens it's just a
little bit higher over here which again
for home theater speakers super
important to have good dynamics in here
and this thing delivers and
part of the reason the space response is
good is because you have the two woofers
in there and the back is not constrained
in a small box so um
from that point of view uh
uh the uh uh oh lost my throne so yeah
so go to a one woofer
you know like a bookshelf speaker you
would have lost a lot of power handling
so
uh if you have to stick a speaker you
know way the heck up by the ceiling
then think twice about using the speaker
because you're basically going to get a
you know your response is going to look
like this so at around 800 hertz to
1.5 or even 2-3 kilohertz
it's just going to have a hole in that
response now maybe for effects channels
and things it doesn't matter i don't
know if you
when we talk about perfection and
execution
instead of lower i mean they don't have
to be as low as your ears but you know
set them like this um you could try to
tilt them a little bit but then they
look odd and you know if you mount them
that way i don't know
so it's a restriction of technology
whenever you have two two woofers and a
tweeter in the middle uh impedance is
typical of modern speakers and that dips
to 3.7 ohm it's usually around this 200
hertz where that happens
and uh so you need to have an amplifier
that can handle uh
low impedance load so don't stick two
bumps and stuff like that
which i don't think anybody would anyway
uh there are some resonances whenever
there are kinks over here like there's
one here there's one here we call those
resonances and uh it's not good but a
lot of speakers have them and who knows
whether this is caused by you know how
it was mounted to that mdf
on this and when you mount it to a rear
wall you're gonna have more of these
things because
you're gonna you know that wall that you
have is not made to be a speaker panel
so
um
we can run a waterfall display and see
the same thing you can see that
that resonance over here and you see
follow-up resonances um i don't you know
this display is almost useless because
if you look every every time there is
one of these things there's also a peak
in frequency response so you could
easily tell that you have a resonance at
every one of these and if you eq that
out this also dies off with it so
that's why you know even though i plot
this csd waterfall it really doesn't
tell you anything new and as i've said
before i can set the parameters where
these things disappear all i've got to
do is move this floor up and these
things just vanish and i can set the
resolution where these some of these
kinks are there when they're not there
so anyway if you
want to be paying attention and stuff is
there i certainly don't pay any
attention to these things but i got
tired of telling people why i don't post
impulse response and step responses so
here they are
basically this is the
twitter response is higher frequency so
it's much narrower and this is a woofer
response it's lower frequency so it
takes more time to settle down
okay
um
the speaker is still sitting on the
stand as you saw it in the picture in
the review i haven't uh yeah i have no
ability to mount it to a real wall and
listen to it i'm not
punching a hole in the wall
these things are not standardized anyway
it's just not practical for me to listen
to it so i'm not gonna
give you a review
assessment of this thing based on
measurements i think it's going to be
extremely good speaker fortunately
fortunately the owner of the speaker
performed a double blind study with
bunch of people with this mounted in a
wall and this speaker finished at the
top so
you have some
confirmation from him and also uh ravel
group at harman will not release the
speaker without double-blind testing
against his competitors and so there's a
lot of arrows pointing to this being a
competent design and by the way it's
only 495 dollars retail
well speakers frequently get discounted
by desperate dealers out there
so you may be able to get it even lower
so to get basically rebel performance
but you but they have to compete with
all these other guys to sell these
little you know in-wall speakers uh
really cheap and so the pricing of them
is very reasonable it's not like
high-end ravel speakers but the
performance is there
okay that's all i have for you uh
hopefully you like all these very varied
reviews i'm trying to do a review on
everything i post every day on on audio
science review so you're getting a broad
exposure to
different products okay see you in a
future video bye